hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new echo show 10.
i'm so excited about this because i've
been such a huge fan of all of the echo
show products since the very beginning a
huge thank you to amazon for sponsoring
this video let's unbox
and get to it
[Music]
what is up dude look at
this
oh this is cool this is gonna be
real cool let's plug in
set up and get going oh
things are happening already
hey what's up
nice tilt action this is cool all right
let's get you all set up
it's previewing the motion is saying
don't move
or unplug your device
now use the slider to set the position
this is where
the screen will face when not in use
that's nice
hello alexa
are you there
yes i'm here i don't even
alexa take a picture
[Music]
like look at this see that it's
beautiful really my best work
alexa follow me following is now on
this is going to keep me entertained for
a very
very long time so this is not going to
be her final home
here in the office i'm going to actually
put this in the kitchen on my center
island
which is going to be a perfect little
home for you
one of the things that i love so much
about using the echo show
is how much it helps me with my
productivity and also
if you guys don't know i like to shop on
amazon quite a lot i mean i basically
buy pretty much everything from amazon
so this makes it super easy to not only
track my shipments but i can order
things just with my voice i can add
things to my shopping cart and this is
also a really great kitchen companion i
wouldn't say that i'm the most
incredible chef ever
but i have the ability to ask my
sous chef any questions that i want like
alexa
how many ounces are in a pound one pound
is 16 ounces
see i would have never been able to
figure that out without her another
really cool thing is you're able to
actually get recipes
and the fact that this has motion
control if i'm trying to cook and do
things around the kitchen i can
constantly
have this device follow me so if i need
to be able to have access to the recipe
that she's pulling up on her screen i
can easily do that alexa how long should
i cook some baked chicken for
here is what i found it is recommended
to bake untrust chicken in the oven for
10 minutes per pound at 500 degrees
fahrenheit and to rest for 10 minutes
until it reaches an internal temperature
of at least 165 degrees fahrenheit
was that helpful yes alexa what should i
make for dinner for dinner
here's a few recipes slow cooker ribs
that looks interesting i think i'm gonna
go with the pasta
and now i have this recipe here i can
save the recipe
i get to be safe even add this to my
shopping list
okay i have added all ingredients to
your shopping list
like what is life i can also have full
access to my shopping list so if there's
something else that i want to add
other than everything that i need right
here to make this recipe alexa
add yerba mate to my shopping list
the ever made added to your shopping
list so you can see that not only did i
add that but i've also got everything
to make that pasta dish many of you
obviously know this device as an
entertainment device so you can watch
videos movies you can watch twitch you
can also use it to play music
which is one of the top things that i
also use this for this is also a really
great smart home hub so you can connect
your lights to it and anything else that
is
alexa enabled you'll be able to control
with your voice
for me i basically use it to control
most of the lights in my house
i also listen to a lot of audio books so
this is also connected to audible so i'm
able to pick up where i left off on any
books that i'm currently listening to
but the number one thing that i really
really
use this for is staying connected with
my friends and my family i'm gonna call
my sister now so i can give you guys a
demo of how not only the tracking works
but what it looks like when you're
actually on a call and you're moving
around walking
calling jenna is eric's alexa devices
yeah let's go get her let's go get her
is that jenna how's it going good look
at me
look at me can you see me
yeah well look at this
[Music]
mine doesn't do that yeah because you
don't have an echo show 10.
whoa that's cool yeah
and it even like will zoom in on me so
like if i'm over here
if i'm just chilling it's like yo
it's pretty cool huh it's pretty cool
yeah i need to upgrade what are you guys
doing over there
you know stuff i do
oh whoa it's pretty cool i'm jealous
you want to see my fridge let me show
you sure
any nervous in there of course
oh look at all those drinks tyler made
apple pizza with apricot
jelly jam and homemade bread homemade
dough
oh my gosh uh tyler from the other room
said he's bringing some for you later so
stay tuned hey do you wanna see my
microwave
[Music]
that's nice thank you very nice that's
nice isn't it
okay let's go that was fun i'll see you
later
bye bye well thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun checking out
this new echo show 10. i'll put a link
in the description if you guys want to
check this out or any other echo show
products i would love to hear from you
guys though what is your favorite echo
show product
do you have some do you not have any and
if you don't have one which one is on
your wish list if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you give it a thumbs up
and hit the bell so you'll be notified
when i post a new video and be sure to
subscribe and i will see you guys
in the next one